[Music]
you know we're quite used to hearing
insane things from the body positivity
camp but yesterday a body positivity
activist and fat acceptance activist
named monica crete
upped the ante considerably on her
social media accounts which have all now
been set to private crete calls herself
a writer consultant educator fighting
weight stigma in public health and
medicine
she also hosts seminars on the topic of
being fat unfortunately you missed the
most recent one hosted alongside
activist mikey mercedes who is a woman
by the way although i didn't have to
tell you that she's a woman because the
body positivity people are always women
can you remember the last time you saw a
man's fatness celebrated
when's the last time one of these body
positivity fat people was a man it like
never happens
because you're still allowed to fat
shame men
it's specifically women who have the
right to balloon to whatever size they
please without any criticism from
anybody so anyway the seminar was titled
fat phobia in public health
and was specifically meant for weight
inclusive dietitians
of course the term weight inclusive
dietitian is a bit like the term
cancer-inclusive oncologist or
cockroach-inclusive pest control you
can't include that is support and
celebrate
the very thing your job requires you to
treat
and destroy
so there are many such contradictions uh
in the world of the body positivity
activists many absurdities and they all
culminate in this tweet for monica she
wrote quote
periodic reminder that treating and
preventing obesity actually means trying
to conversion therapy fat people into
becoming thin people despite zero
evidence that this is remotely possible
you heard that right
monica the consultant and educator says
that dieting is a form of conversion
therapy
and moreover that there is zero evidence
that dieting actually makes anyone
skinnier
monica believes or wants you to believe
anyway that caloric intake actually has
nothing at all to do with weight
what about all the millions of people
who have managed to drop weight by
limiting calories well they're all
mythological they don't exist
if you're one of those people you don't
exist i'm sorry to say or else you're
part of a grand fat phobic conspiracy
a conspiracy which which includes almost
every doctor and nutritionist in the
world by the way
and what about the fact that starving
people always tend to be very skinny so
that's a coincidence
and the fact that obesity is only common
in western countries where people eat a
lot of food and hardly move
what about the almost complete absence
of obesity in the third world for that
matter what about the fact that our
skeletons and internal organs literally
were not made to carry the kind of
weight that monica and her fellow fat
activists are forcing their skeletons
and organs to carry
that's why fat people die young that's
why there are no morbidly obese 85 year
olds
your body at that age just can't can't
handle it can't con it can't carry all
that weight around anymore
what about that
don't all of these facts point
incontrovertibly to the notion that you
get fat when you eat a lot and get
skinny when you eat less
no says monica
don't ask her to explain herself either
it makes her feel good to see the world
the way she sees it and your job is to
enforce whatever perception of the world
and herself makes her feel good
that's your sacred responsibility
because she says so
now as crazy as all this is
the most revealing aspect is the way
that she uses the term fat people and
skinny people
now she doesn't mean fat and skinny as a
mere description of a transient physical
trait
what she said when she says fat people
she does not mean
people who happen to have an unhealthy
amount of lard on their bodies
now for her fat is an immutable and
defining characteristic it's an identity
it's who she is deep inside it's her
very soul is fat
fatness is an identity
i tell you we're only months away since
i'm making predictions today on the show
i can also tell you this we're only
months away from somebody coming up with
a special pronouns for fat people
which will give a whole new meaning to
the term trans fat
and i'm not joking about the pronouns in
our culture the special pronoun it's how
you affirm and consecrate an identity
it's like a baptism
and the good thing is that the blessed
pronouns though they are supposed to
have this mystical significance can
change any time well i know some of you
are sleeping on some saggy old
mattresses at night i know because i'm
watching you while you sleep and i see
but you deserve better than that so give
yourself an upgrade helix sleep has a
quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete and matches your body type of
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you if you like a mattress
that's really soft or firm if you sleep
on your side or your back your stomach
or your sleep really hot with helix
there is a specific mattress for each
and everybody's unique taste you don't
need to take their word for it either
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress of 2019 and 2020 by gq
and wired magazine you can see for
yourself why that's the case just go to
helixsleep.com walsh take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
so you're risking nothing you might as
well give it a shot right now helix is
offering up to 200 off and free pillows
with all mattress orders for our
listeners at helix sleep dot com slash
walsh that's helix sleep dot com slash
walls for up to 200 off your mattress
order so just for fun let's look at
another example of this phenomenon
dipping into the tick tock well with the
help of our friend libs of tick tick
tock who found this one um here's a
woman announcing her new pronouns listen
to this
hey guys i think it's finally time for
an update on my gender series i'm not
gonna lie i have no idea what part this
is but
let's go
okay first off um i am now just going by
k now um i no longer like to be called
kayla um unless it's
for work
uh just because it's kind of confusing
with the paperwork and stuff so yeah i
also am now using all pronouns instead
of none
um
i don't regret not going by any pronouns
before but
i do feel that
i
it just makes i don't know it just
that's what's happening
another thing though i am still
xenogender um i still
that is still my gender that i identify
with and i am still bisexual so those
things have not changed at all
so yeah this is just a little quick
update um that i have for you all and
i don't know
just let me know if you have any
questions um i'd love to answer them
okay make sure to update your scoreboard
uh now uh
kayla is now k
she's still zeno gender whatever that is
but um
she went from no pronouns to all
pronouns
that's that's that's the update
now how could she have had no pronouns
before did she not exist was she some
kind of phantom or something
and how can she go by all pronouns now
what does she really mean all pronouns
even like it
can i call her an it
i suppose so
she is a man a woman a thing a nothing
and everything
she is all things and nothing she
transcends time and space she's like
some sort of pantheistic deity
and you better not so much as suggest
otherwise because your job again is to
affirm as we've learned to do anything
less than a firm to express even mild
disagreement with a person's self
perception is to engage in conversion
therapy and conversion therapy is the
ultimate sin because it's an attack on a
person's self-identity which is to say
that it's an attack on their entire
world on their reality
because they recognize no world or
reality aside from the one they've
created in their heads
now
i want to get a little bit more
philosophical here
so let's bring together fat acceptance
stuff
pronouns
uh hysteria about conversion therapy and
all the rest of it
what's what's really going on
i think what's happening is that is that
we are conscious beings to begin with
um we are aware of ourselves
aware of our own fragility and
impermanence
and as far as we know we're the only
creatures in the universe cursed with
such an awareness
so we find ourselves floating in this
vast ocean of existence wondering about
the reason and the purpose for it all
we came from non-existence
and will fade back into the abyss
from which we came at least physically
and we know all of that
the only way to survive is to reach out
for an anchor point you know something
stable
try to find an island to rest on
because we can't be conscious beings
floating along with no purpose and yet
aware of it the whole time we can't do
that indefinitely there's just no way to
live you can't live that way
people who try to live that way end up
not living for very long
the problem that we face in the west is
that
we had an anchor
we had an island but we abandoned it
we gave up on god on religion which was
our source of identity our sense of
purpose our solid ground
we decided that it wasn't good enough
for us so we jump back into the sea with
no real idea of where else to go instead
so now we're adrift aimless and
meandering and totally susceptible to
any storm that comes along we have no
shelter from it no escape from the
crashing waves what we're witnessing
with the proliferation of gender
identities the pronoun madness the fat
except and stuff are a bunch of drowning
adrift people
reaching out for anchors for little
islands for some kind of stability and
identity
having traded in the one true source of
stability and identity available to us
but these anchors aren't really anchors
because they're not anchored in anything
they don't go all the way down to the
sea floor
the islands are just driftwood at best
they don't provide the sense of purpose
and belonging and worth that these
people want from them which is why
they're always trading them out for
something else
but really they're still lost in the sea
hopeless and alone
so i guess it's a good thing that fat
people are more buoyant in second
thought
i had a good philosophical thing going
there i had i ruined it with a fat joke
i should have done that but i did in any
case the point is monica crete the fat
acceptance activist is today canceled
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated